hello my name is Bassam silly i am
general manager for international
markets for Petra solar out of New
Jersey my view on sustaining and
creating jobs in the Arab world is that
we need in the Arab world to create
institutions to bridge the gap between
the public domain the government
academia and the private sector we see
that the private sector is struggling
really to find niches within the Arab
world to have business and to create
jobs financing institutions need to have
a stability of sorts to be able to
mitigate risk and such institutions
would help we look at the world economic
forum as a bridge actually to help bring
the best models in the Western world to
the air world and hopefully we feel that
their world should learn from these
sessions from the World Economic Forum
and we're here to help so reach out to
us as well thank you